Ms Seven years after my graduation day,
I had failed on an epic scale,
an exceptionally short lift.
Marriage had imploded and I was jobless
alone parent and as poor as it is
possible to be in modern Britain without
being homeless.
The fears that my parents had had for me
and that I had had for myself had both
come to pass and by every usual standard
I was the biggest failure.
I knew.
Now I'm not going to stand here and tell
you that failure is fun.
That period of my life was a dark one
and I had no idea that there was going
to be what the press has said since
represented as a kind of fairy tale
resolution.
I have no idea then how far the tunnel
extended and for a long time any light
at the end of it was a hope rather than
a reality.
So why do I talk about the benefits of
failure?
Simply because failure,
mental stripping away of the
inessential,
I stopped pretending to myself that I
was anything other than what I was and
began to direct all my energy into
finishing.
The only work that mattered to me had I
really succeeded at anything else,
I might never have found the
determination to succeed in the one
arena where I believed I truly belonged.
I was set free because my greatest fear
had been realized and I was still alive
and I still had a daughter whom I adored
and I had an old typewriter and a big
idea,
and so rock bottom became the solid
foundation on which I rebuilt my life.
You might never fail on the scale I did,
but some failure in life is inevitable.
It is impossible to live without failing
at something unless you live so
cautiously that you might as well not
have lived at all,
in which case you fail.
By default.
Fadia gave me an inner security that I
have never attained by passing
examinations.
Failure taught me things about myself
that I could have learned no other way.
I discovered that I had a strong will
and more disciplined than I has
suspected.
I also found out that I had friends
whose value was truly above the price of
rubis.
The knowledge that you have emerged
wiser and stronger from setbacks.
It means that you are ever after secure
in your ability to survive.
You will never truly know yourself.
All the strength of your relationships
until both have been tested by
adversity.
Such knowledge is a true gift for all
the titties,
painfully one,
and it has been worth more than any
qualification I ever earned.